we're very excited now to reveal the
cover of our very first CBS this morning
book it's called note to self inspiring
words from inspiring people features 26
notes from our Emmy nominated series
where prominent figures write letters to
their younger selves now since the
series began six years ago we featured
more than 30 different notes the book
includes letters from Vice President Joe
Biden Oprah and astronaut Peggy Whitson
dear Joe you're only 12 your stutter is
debilitating it embarrasses you and the
bullies are vicious listen to mom when
she says bravery resides in every heart
and yours is fierce and clear from where
I sit now viewing your journey there
really are very few regrets lives
there's one
that means a life well-lived I'll just
say challenge yourself you will learn
that you are so much more capable than
you might imagine
or even dream sincerely they older you
the book will be published by Simon &
Schuster that's a division of CBS it
goes on sale in May and I think the
thinking is June graduation could be a
very nice graduation gift that's one of
my favorite things that we do here I
think those are always so well done and
so revealing Peggy Whitson for instance
did hers in space and then again on the
ground sound a one message if you get no
others is life is long that's right over
do it that's right and Peggy talked
about her father and her message huge
obviously brought a tear to my eye and
so many of us as well